- HEY, HEY, HEY, ALL RIGHT.
- HEY.
- HI, SWEETIE,
THAT'S FOR YOU.
- HEY, TRACE.
HOW YOU DOING, GIRL?
- CHECK IT OUT.
- OH, MY.
- GIRL, I GOT A SUNKEN TUB.
YOU GOT TO SEE IT.
- OH, I GOT TO SEE THIS.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YOU TWO
HAVE A GOOD TIME NOW.
- HAVE FUN, HAVE FUN.
[door closes]
DUDE, I AM SORRY
WE'RE LATE, MAN.
- MAN, IT HAPPENS, MAN.
- AND SHE TALK ABOUT HOW
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE IN THE CAR
AT 6:45,
I'M LIKE, "ALL RIGHT."
- UH-OH.
- TELL ME MY DUMB ASS
AIN'T SITTING IN THE CAR,
WAITING UNTIL 7:15.
- NUH-UH.
- OKAY, WHEN I TRACK MY WIFE
DOWN 20 MINUTES LATER,
SHE'S STEPPING OUT
THE DAMN SHOWER TALKING ABOUT,
"CAN I HELP YOU?"
- SEE, THAT'S CRAZY
RIGHT THERE.
- I LOOKED THIS WOMAN
IN THE EYE, I SAID,
"BITCH, YOU TOLD ME 6:45."
- YOU SAID THAT?
- PSH, YEAH I SAID--
"BITCH."
THEN I LAID IT OUT.
- BUT YOU SAID, "BITCH,"
THOUGH?
- HMM?
- YOU SAID, "BITCH"?
- YEAH.
- YOU GOT TO SEE THE FIREPLACE
DOWNSTAIRS IN THE LIVING ROOM.
- OKAY.
- DON'T PLAY GAMES, MAN.
JUST TELL ME WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO TELL ME.
- EXACTLY, IT'S LIKE,
SAY WHAT YOU MEAN,
MEAN WHAT YOU SAY.
- IS THAT SO HARD?
- IT'S LIKE LAST WEEK, MAN.
WE GOING OUT TO DINNER,
RIGHT?
I'M LIKE,
"WHERE DO YOU WANT TO GO?"
SHE'S LIKE, "YOU DECIDE."
- UH-OH.
- I'M LIKE, "ALL RIGHT,
OUTBACK STEAKHOUSE."
SHE LIKE, "NAH."
- MM-HMM.
- I'M LIKE,
"STRAIGHT UP, CHILI'S."
SHE'S LIKE, "EHH."
- NO, NO.
- DARRELL, I NAMED
SEVEN MORE RESTAURANTS.
- NO, CRAIG, NO.
- I FINALLY SAID,
"TAYLOR'S," THE PLACE I KNOW
SHE WANTS TO GO
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
- RIGHT, RIGHT.
- SHE LOOK AT ME, SHE SAID,
"IF THAT'S WHERE
YOU WANT TO GO."
- NO, SHE DIDN'T, CRAIG.
- IF THAT'S WHERE
I WANT TO GO.
DARRELL, I LOOKED MY WOMAN
IN THE EYE SOCKETS.
I TOLD HER STRAIGHT OUT,
I JUST SAID IT, MAN, I SAID IT.
I SAID, I SAID, I SAID--
I SAID, "BI..."
- HEY, GUYS.
- HEY GIRL, HOW YOU DOING?
- OH, HOW YOU DOING?
- YOU HAVING A GOOD TIME?
- YOU SEEN THE BEDROOM?
- JUST LOOKING AT THE WOOD.
- THAT WASHING MACHINE IS HUGE.
- UP ON THE CEILING HERE.
- YOU GET A WHOLE BUNCH OF
CLOTHES IN THAT WASHING MACHINE.
- HEY, BABY, I'M GOING TO TAKE
HER BACK UP TO THE KITCHEN
AND SHOW HER THE DISHWASHER.
- DARRELL?
- YEAH, BABY?
- I WANT A KITCHEN ISLAND
JUST LIKE THE ONE UPSTAIRS.
- YOU GONNA GET IT TOO.
- I LOVE YOU.
- I SAID, "BITCH,
IF YOU WANTED TO GO TO TAYLOR'S,
JUST TELL A BROTHER
YOU WANT TO GO TO TAYLOR'S!"
OKAY?
- YOU SAID THAT?
- OH, HELL YEAH, MAN.
I LAID IT OUT, RIGHT?
I SAYS--I SAYS--I SAYS--
I SAID, "BITCH,
I'M THE MAN OF THE HOUSE."
- YOU SAID, "BITCH," THOUGH?
- HMM?
- YOU CALLED
YOUR WIFE A BITCH?
- UH-HUH, YEAH.
- CRAIG.
- DARRELL.
- WHERE ARE THOSE GUYS?
- I DON'T KNOW.
LET'S GO...
- SO SHE'S LIKE,
"WHY DON'T YOU RENT A MOVIE
WE BOTH LIKE?"
- NO, SHE DIDN'T.
- AFTER I SPENT 25 MINUTES
IN THE GODDAMN BLOCKBUSTER.
CRAIG, I LOOKED THIS WOMAN
IN HER OPTIC STEMS AND I SAYS--
I SAID--
I SAYS, "BITCH."
- YOU SAID THAT?
- AIN'T NOTHING
BUT A THING.
- BUT YOU SAID, "BITCH,"
THOUGH?
- YEP.
- SEE...
[phone rings]
- OH, SH--
HEY, HONEY, CRAIG'S JUST
GIVING ME THE NEIGHBORHOOD TOUR.
- SO THEN SHE'S LIKE,
"I DIDN'T KNOW WE'D BE DOING
SO MUCH WALKING."
- NUH-UH.
- I'M LIKE, "I DIDN'T TELL YOU
TO WEAR THOSE SHOES."
SHE SAID, "DON'T RAISE
YOUR VOICE AT ME."
- WHAT?
- DARRELL, I LOOKED THIS WOMAN
DEAD IN THE WINDOWS OF HER SOUL.
- MM-HMM.
- I SAID--
I SAID...
[door opens, air hisses]
I SAID, "BITCH."